Hello
I am Celine and I am sitting right now after a long day
on the couch but today something exciting happened
and that is I got the message
that I have for the EM 24
in the field of social media uh for Hamburg have been accepted as a volunteer
and yes
I thought I would take you a little bit
I am curious how it continues
I accepted this today because you had to give your dress sizes
full many different bragging for polo shirt t shirt
rain jacket and shoes
ah and long and short pants so super super much um
yes i am curious how it goes on now
you probably get this and then next month the deployment plan
then it's time to submit vacation for the days and
yes I am super excited uh how the whole will be and how it goes on
I will definitely take you with me